[Music]
hello everyone i'm very pleased to
welcome today one of my
one of the writers i i admire um
for the content and for the quality of
the prose itself
he's been compared to george orwell
uh which is high praise indeed as one of
england's
uh as one of great britain's finest
essayists
uh dr anthony daniels better known by
his pen name theodore del rimple
he worked as a prison doctor and
psychiatrist retired in 2005
but worked all over the world and
traveled and
he's written many books some of which
have had
a rather profound cultural impact
including life at the bottom the world
view that makes the underclass
2001 where he discusses what you might
describe
as the philosophy of poverty our culture
what's left of it
the mandarins and the masses 2005 not
with a bang
but a whimper the politics and culture
of decline 2008
spoiled rotten the toxic cult of
sentimentality
2010 and the terror of existence with
catholic theologian kenneth francis in
for the spectator he wrote a weekly
column on his experiences as a prison
doctor
for 14 years those were later collected
in various books
he wrote a weekly column for the british
medical journal as well
for six years discussing medicine and
literature
his essays have appeared in the finest
newspapers and magazines in the world
including the times the
spectator and the wall street journal
welcome and
thank you very much for agreeing to talk
with me well thank you for asking me
i'm i'm going to start by telling you
how i found out about you
i when i was working as a clinical
psychologist
i had a social worker as a client who
immigrant second generation immigrant
female who had been
a rather radically leftist thinker in
her youth
and then spent 20 years in the social
work trenches
and was eventually hounded out of her
profession
pounded out and bullied out of her
profession by
the radical leftists themselves and she
mentioned life at the bottom to me
and so i picked it up and read it and i
thought i've never heard anyone
state this so bluntly and what what
struck me i guess was
was three things was the
you're apart from the quality of your
writing and the content
um you're the the particularities of
your experience
you said for example that you had dealt
with
poverty with people who were in poverty
in various places
in the world africa for example and
then in great britain in the inner
cities in
what you regard as the underclass a
permanent multi-generational uh segment
of society
that are in some sense they've fallen
out of the bottom of the culture
in your view and but what you you
concentrated
you you focused on the difference
between that poverty
and the poverty of absolute deprivation
that you
encountered in places like africa but
then you added another twist to it which
was
you made a very very strong case that
there was a philosophy
in some sense or maybe an
anti-philosophy
but it boils down to the same thing a
world view
that constituted the essence
of the poverty that you saw in great
britain
which you also regarded in many regard
in many ways as
more severe and less addressable than
the poverty that you had seen in
in other in the developing world for
example so it was your combination of
broad worldly experience intense
involvement with the underclass that so
many people
feel morally obliged to save in some
sense but actually never interact with
your experience as a psychiatrist and
then your willingness to put down these
very critical and and
and certainly politically incorrect
by virtually every measure observations
which to me
rang true generally true and
which i hadn't encountered with any
other thinker
yes well i didn't really start out with
any
uh preconception certainly not any
political preconception i just
i just saw a lot of patients and uh
and the penny began to drop about
what their lives were like and what they
expected from
life and who did you see tell tell
everyone about
about the world i worked in an inner
city hospital
the inner city hospital was right next
door to the prison
and the main difference between these
two great institutions was
that far more violence in the hospital
than in the prison but
and i would work in the morning in the
hospital and then i would go and work
in our prison in the afternoon
and and often at night and weekends as
well
so in the in the hospital i saw
maybe something in the region of
i didn't count exactly 10 to 15 000
cases
of attempted suicide or at least of
suicidal gestures
that varied from you know real attempts
at suicide
to attempts to bring
bring parents to heal everything in
between
but anyway everyone i i examined
them all or when i say examined i mean i
spoke to them all and of course they
told me about
uh the life around them so they told me
about the
about the uh about the lives of people
around them
and so in the end i probably heard about
the lives of
maybe 40 50 000
people of course refracted through
through these people's lenses but
nevertheless
though it was a selected sample of
people it wasn't a small sample of
people
and so obviously i
i began to draw some conclusions see
some generalizations which i didn't
start with
so and so we could talk about the
selection for a minute i mean
you because you were working the
hospital and in the prison you obviously
saw people who were hospitalized or who
were in prison
and so obviously there's a selection
there but you your
your patients were drawn from lower
socioeconomic strata so they were
poor and dispossessed but comparatively
speaking
but and there they had got into
trouble of one form or another that was
sufficiently damaging so that they ended
up
being brought to the attention of the
medical authorities because of
the own the damage that had been
inflicted on them or prison authorities
because of the damage that they
inflicted on other people
so that's the selection it would be poor
people
relatively poor people who were also in
trouble
and yes and you you you said you didn't
start with political intent while you're
a psychiatrist
um but well walk us through what you saw
if you would
and over and over and and what what you
started to conclude and why you started
to communicate it
well i i'll deal with why i started to
communicate
it was that it was so terrible uh
that it would uh uh
that i would have found it very
difficult to keep it to myself and
remain
sane in fact the my predecessor in the
job i found uh
little bottles of vodka everywhere where
he
he went because i think he had found it
extremely difficult
it was very very distressing once for
example i
kept a a diary of what i saw every day
rather than rather than
mold it in a kind of literary fashion
for articles i just wrote down
what i saw and after a very short time
actually only a few days i thought i
can't go on
with this first of all no one would want
to read it it's just too terrible
so actually things were worse than i
described in my book
now what i saw was a complete social
what seemed to me as such complete
social breakdown
i mean there were almost no families in
the sense of mother
father and children that was almost
unknown
in the area practically unknown if you
ask
16 year olds who their father is they
replied with things like
do you mean my father at the moment
or they would say when i say who is your
father they just say no
well i when i went i was listening to
your book this morning
uh life at the bottom at 2.5 times
normal speed and
it was quite the i mean i'd read it
before but
i i had forgotten
what the it's an unending litany of
complete
calamity across every dimension you can
possibly imagine
and then you said you saw like 20 000 of
people who were in dire suicidal straits
in addition i
i presumed that you had patients other
than those who were suicidal as well
yes well mainly because i was working in
a general it was a general hospital
then i would see organic patients with
organic
problems and a few others people who'd
been
beaten by their partners oh i saw that
that was standard of course
i mean i i discovered that about 80
percent of the
women whom i saw
had suffered violence at the hands of
their
one or more of their sexual partners
well we could dig
in there you tell this story that's
really quite interesting so
you're and very
what would you say uh libel
any discussion of it is liable to create
controversy
so you you talked about the women that
you saw the patients who
chronically chose males
who you could identify at a glance
as extraordinarily likely to
burst into violent jealous rages and
become physically violent and you also
point out that
the markers for that were not precisely
subtle
comparing the men that you were looking
at i believe
to your neighbors tomcat who had been in
enough fights so his
head was a mass of shredded ears and
scars and
missing an eye and so these were men who
had shaved heads multiple scars
from battles um often tattooed often
tattooed
on their fists with blatant messages of
nihilism
or or social rejection or anger or
or threats or curse words or
um so it wasn't exactly subtle
these and you said that they invariably
wore
a uh an expression of contempt
something like that and they were people
you would obviously give wide birth to
in the street in broad daylight yet
they were in invariably tangled up with
a woman
or two or three or ten who they were
abusing serially
but and the the women seemed
um in some sense blind to this but not
only the
underclass women that you were serving
but you also mentioned that that was
extraordinarily
prevalent among the nursing staff
and so to walk us through that and tell
us how
you make sense of that well it wasn't uh
i wouldn't say it was prevalent amongst
the nursing staff it was present
at present in the nursing staff
well my interpretation which would be of
course
uh regarded as highly reactionary in the
end this is the conclusion i came to
was that because sexual relations had
been
freed from all um
contractual cultural
um economic
uh restraint and constraint then what
was left
was a kind of free-for-all and the men
uh wanted exclusive sexual possession of
somebody but at the same time they
wanted exclusive they wanted
complete sexual freedom now these things
don't go
together very well i mean uh if there's
complete
sexual freedom okay it has complete
sexual freedom but if at the same time
you want possibly for reasons of
boosting your self-image the exclusive
sexual possession of somebody
then and everyone around you is the same
then the men would see other men as
threats
so they would be and they would become
extremely jealous
um because they would fear any
any uh contact between
their girlfriend they were never wise
girlfriend
with another man would lead to or might
lead
to a liaison and after all since they
were sexually predatory in this
in that way uh they assumed that
everyone around them
uh was was of similar ilk
and which was often true and this this
used to lead to fights for example
in um in so-called nightclubs
which uh i mean when i was young a
nightclub was a
place where there was a floor show and
little tables around but
these were great cabins of of
thousands of people where if one
where if a man looked at a girlfriend
it was assumed to be a challenge by the
girlfriend's boyfriend and
and so there could be fights and even
murder
so i got in trouble with the new york
times because i pointed out at one
one point during the discussion with
this journalist that
societies all around the world and i
thought of this as a universal
anthropological truth and something that
was well established to the point of
being self-evident but apparently not
that a major problem that every society
faces is the
control of aggression by young men in
particular and generally as a
consequence of sexual
jealousy and striving and the universal
answer to that
insofar as there is one was the
development of monogamous norms and
social enforcement of those norms and
you know you you just described it in
some sense as
inhibition and control but i i think
it's also useful
and to think about it as integration and
into a more sophisticated game um
you know being in a marriage obviously
does involve not
chasing after other people sexually but
it isn't all inhibitory within the
marriage
something sophisticated and hopefully
wonderful
in the long term is supposed to occur as
a
preferable substitute
and i mean preferable if it's done
properly to the short-term gratification
that might be
obtained by serial relationships say
or sporadic relationships because
they're they're actually very difficult
and they also produce these violent
outcomes that you described and
i was pilloried for that in quite a
remarkable way
claims were made that you know i was
making the claim
that governments should you know
hand over unwilling women to undesirable
monogamous men or undesirable men just
to enforce monogamy but really what i
meant was well
part one of the reasons for marriage
apart from the fact that two fem
two parent families are clearly much
better for children
when the with the father there is that
societies that
allow unregulated polygamy or that
degenerate into that
are invariably rife with in
extraordinarily high levels of violence
yes well that's what i i saw now
uh of course what the the the
destruction of the idea of of
the family as we once knew it
has been a long process started i think
by intellectuals literary intellectuals
and it's perfectly true that a bad
marriage from which you can't escape
is hell i mean it's a kind of
concentrated hell
and
marriage is not easy
so people thought well i think this is
this is my explanation
they thought that there were if if
we could get rid of all the inhibitions
and restraints
and frustrations because there are
frustrations
um then the full beauty of the
human personality would emerge and we
would
associate with one another just by
love and nothing else and when love was
over then you just
you just uh go on to something else
somebody
somebody else but this is actually
a very shallow view of things apart from
anything else in a marriage if a
marriage if there are difficulties in
the way of
ending a marriage this gives you
actual incentives to make it work
it also tells you that society values
what you're doing
yeah which helps you continue to value
it which makes you
likely to stick more likely to stick
with it during periods of doubt i mean
obviously life is extraordinarily
difficult and
just on its own and and it's certainly
no easier if you're alone that's for
sure
and so life is difficult when you have a
partner and
because of that difficulty but not
because of anything necessarily
intrinsic to the state of marriage
itself
you need social institutions to buttress
the structure
so that all of the weight doesn't fall
on those individuals alone you know i
mean i've had clients in my practice who
are living together
and you know when i ask them why they
don't get married the man
often will say well we don't need a
piece of paper to signify our commitment
and i think
first i've heard that 20 times and you
might think that's a philosophy but it's
actually a pretty stunningly shallow
cliche
and second um we're not talking about a
piece of paper here
we're actually talking about something
serious you stand up in front of your
family your peers your friends the
people that love you
the people that you want to spend time
with hypothetically for the rest of your
life
that you're going to depend on that are
going to depend on you
and you say look this is important i
want you to recognize it
we're now one thing we're going to give
it our best shot
and it would be nice if you support us
and that's not trivial it's
vital and that's still why i think
marriage may be less frequent especially
among the lower classes
than it once was although cohabiting
isn't
or perhaps it is as well but um romance
movies that feature
a wedding are certainly not any less
popular and marriage is still
just as popular among the upper classes
which is something you also discuss
in books like uh the mandarins and the
masses for example
you're not very happy with these
philosophical discussions of freedom
conducted by people say like jean-paul
sartre
and the absolutely catastrophic
consequences of that unbridled thinking
on people who are at the bottom of the
hierarchy
yes with regard to the
piece of paper business i remember i had
a patient
who had uh and she was not a foolish
woman
had taken tried to kill herself
eventually unfortunately did kill
herself
she wanted very much a man to marry her
and the man didn't want to marry her but
he wanted to
cohabit with her and i remember him
saying to me
i don't see what what she's
uh what she's worried about it's only a
piece of paper
and i said well if it's only a piece of
paper why don't you sign it
because it's only a piece of paper
either way
so obviously this revealed that it
wasn't only a piece of paper
it was a commitment which he was
unwilling or for some reason
uh to make he had to he had personally
well there's also the
the question of well what what is the
basis of your relationship if it isn't
actually a a a a formally recognized
permanent commitment
say you're cohabiting with someone i
think in canada it's six months and it's
basically common law marriage
so what is it is we're going to hang
around with each other until one of us
finds someone better but you'll do for
now
is that the like i don't know what well
i think yes i think it's uh
it's uh particularly with the men i
think
they uh they don't want to close off all
possibilities
they think you see they think that
having
an infinite choice is actually not
committing to anything
uh which of course is a mistake
and what do you think it is committing
to
which uh the the the continual
the hypothetical continual choice uh
that is just uh they hope to be able to
um to continue a life of uh
pleasure and um
and sensation i think that that's about
it
um and they don't want to
uh they have a kind of anti-romantic
idea
um of um
of love so do you think that the
intellectuals
that were actively engaged in the
destruction of
traditional structures or in the
criticism of traditional structures were
just
so well protected by the fact of those
structures that they were only
able to see the residual problems
i think that that was it yes and of
course they were also protected
economically
because economics does make a big
difference here
i mean i know that
in practice the upper classes uh
at least uh they preserve their
hypocrisy
if they break the rules they at least
pretend not to be breaking that or try
to pretend not to be breaking the rules
on the whole um but they are protected
from
consequences of breakdown to some extent
not in completely of course because
there's an emotional
aspect but but money does make a big
difference but if you
have no money
and you have no support or the only
support you have is a rather miserable
support of the state
uh then the consequences are absolutely
terrible and um
and i you know i saw hundreds and
thousands of cases
so there's increasing support in the eu
for example for schemes such as a
universal basic
income and you know you just made an
argument
that at least from one perspective could
be viewed as
supportive of a scheme like that given
that
if you have a dearth of material
resources a dearth of money
you're much more vulnerable to
catastrophe
and so you might think well if we grant
people a minimum basic income
that eradicates that problem
but you also tie the degeneration that
you saw
which i want to talk about more um to
the rise of the welfare state
and so and one of the things that
and i think this is because of my
clinical experience and it isn't
clear to me that giving
people money actually solves the problem
of
poverty it because poverty is very much
more complex
than the mere lack of money even though
that's certainly a cardinal element of
poverty
and that's the other thing i would say
or another thing that you
pushed at constantly in your writings is
that
there's an entire world view that is
associated with
violent and catastrophic poverty and
that's not precisely an economic issue
even though economic issues might
exaggerate its danger
so tell us some stories and and tell us
what you concluded from
from what you watched well
i concluded that we had created
quite a lot of people who had nothing to
hope for
and nothing to fear perceive of a life
different from
the life they had going to work wouldn't
make much difference to them
economically as
failing to go to work would
not make much difference to them
this isn't actually necessary a
necessary
aspect of the of the welfare state after
all
britain was far worse in this risk in
these respects
than um other countries which have
welfare states in some cases more
generous than the british welfare state
but it but the british welfare state
created people a class of people who
were
permanently in this condition
and had no real incentive to get out of
it
um
so um this created a kind of
it created sometimes a latitude but it
was also dishonest
it created a kind of dishonesty because
actually the more problems they made for
themselves
the more they were rewarded
i remember we had a peculiar
demoralized of the world i don't mean
uh i mean actual removal of morality
from all
human consideration i remember once
i had a patient with
multiple sclerosis and her husband
worked
but he didn't earn a lot of money and
she had multiple sclerosis which were
clearly
not her fault and they needed some
adjustments to their house
so that she could get out of the house
more easily
and so on and it seemed to me this
as far as i'm concerned that's a
perfectly good way to
this is a place where the where the
welfare state could actually
help so i phoned a social worker
and i made a great mistake i said
i have a particularly deserving case oh
yes
and there was a stony silence on the
other end
and then she said that all cases were
deserving
in other words you couldn't distinguish
between
this case of need which was
just one of those things it was nobody's
fault
and someone who
[Music]
took drugs set fire to his house in a
state of intoxication
there was no there was no difference
and since of course people who behave
badly become
more needy they actually gain more
attention
and more sympathy that's if you
if you take dessert away if you remove
dessert
from all considerations
and this means that actually one source
of
meaning in life is completely removed
and what we saw with these people who
had no that's the case you're making
it's not even just
removed it's actually punished actively
punished
yeah which is even worse than mere
removal yeah and you kind of claim i
think and
correct me if i'm wrong that there's a
perverse attractiveness of that to the
educated helping classes in producing a
group of people
who are so much beneath them in some
sense that normal moral standards don't
don't anymore apply and what that means
i mean if that's the case that perverse
sense of superiority and
the moral gratification that might
provide if that's the case then
people are being actively punished for
doing anything that might lift them out
of the circumstances
that they find themselves in yeah well i
think one of the things that's um
that is clear about the
shall i say the intellectual classes is
one of their greatest fears
is the fear of being considered
sensorious
and of course sensoriousness is not a
very attractive quality
so and the but the best way to
avoid being considered sensorious is to
fail to make any judgement whatever
but this is this is completely
impossible it's impossible
to uh not uh to
to um to make judgments judgment
is part of being human um yeah well you
can't perceive without
judging because you have to select the
thing you should be looking at from
everything else you might be looking at
so every act is hierarchical and
implies a value structure and a choice i
mean choice
imposes the necessity to make judgments
now if you pretend that you're not
making judgments
then you are actually facilitating the
worst
judgments so uh
but as i said i think the the
intellectuals
and i mean i i i have this fear myself
when i wrote i thought
is anyone going to think you are an
unfeeling censorious person
because you i mean after all i'm
comparatively fortunate
here i am coming into the lives of
people who
are unfortunate many of them are
unfortunate there's no question about
that
many of them you know they're born in a
low social class they've been given an
extremely bad educational there's
actually quite costly education
but it's extremely bad uh and so on and
so forth
and here i am coming in and making
making judgment saying your behavior
uh is what is causing your unhappiness
uh is at the is that the root of your
unhappiness
and actually i try to de-medicalize a
lot of
their unhappiness because uh
i i didn't think their unhappiness was a
medical condition
um so uh well that is the danger
with judgment i mean i faced this with
my clinical clients constantly but also
in the case of my daughter
and in my own life for that matter if
you're dealing with someone who's
ill it's very difficult to
encourage and it's very difficult to
discipline
and by that i mean encourage and instill
discipline which is something that you
want to do if you're a parent
if your child is ill you it's very
difficult to tell
when the illness is sufficient reason so
that something
isn't being done right and so when
you're dealing with dispossessed people
you have the same problem
yeah well judgment is always fallible so
i would never say that i had never made
any
mistakes in my judgment you know
sometimes i would be too harsh maybe and
sometimes
i wouldn't be hard enough but the i
but the uh i mean that's just
a consequence of um not having enough
knowledge and so on and so forth
but to pretend you're not making a
judgment
is itself a judgment i mean you're
judging that it's
that you shouldn't make judgments it's
also the abdication of responsibility i
mean i thought this through
with my clinical clients at a sort of a
technical level too i
i learned a lot from reading carl rogers
and i would say a certain amount of
unthinking sentimentality
can be laid at his feet in the clinical
and social work world partly because he
proposed that
unconditional positive regard for
his clients was the appropriate pathway
forward
and his critics pointed out that
if you watched carl rogers in action
what he was practicing involved
careful discrimination
but what he meant was something like
accept that the person is a fundamental
value
and has the capacity to move towards the
light
let's say and work in that vein but what
what i would tell my clients
and this was a consequence of my real my
realization that judgment was not only
necessary but crucially
important to forward movement was that
i'm not offering you unconditional
positive regard i'm on the side of the
part of you that wants things to be
better and i'm going to help you
discriminate between the part of you
that doesn't want things to be better
that might even want them to be actively
worse for all sorts of reasons that all
people are prey to
and the part of you that is striving to
make everything better and we'll discuss
what better means and we'll
negotiate the strategies but let's make
it clear
this enterprise is to get rid of what is
undesirable
and to foster what is desirable and to
critically
distinguish between those two which is
absolutely vital
you can throw your hands up and say i'm
not going to be judgmental but
all that that means you're not
distinguishing between what's good and
what isn't
well i think the what i was what i tried
to get out was
with patients was are if you if you like
our existential
equality that i made choices but they
made choices too
i mean of course there were there are
conditions where
where that is not so and you have to
make the distinction between
those cases where people really do not
have
any capability i mean there are such
cases of course
but in the prison for example
one thing that made me a little bit
optimistic was that i never said
anything
in my articles that i didn't actually
say to the patients
and the patients understood on the whole
i mean there were a few
in the prison who i think were
not reachable by this kind of
argumentation but for example i would
not
i in the prison i
said i would not allow the prisoners
to swear in front of me and
um i had no means of stopping them of
course and if they continued i couldn't
refuse to treat
them on the grounds that they had sworn
in from me but i did actually stop them
and i i mean why do you think they
stopped
ah well i i provided i provided an
argument
i i don't know whether one is allowed to
use bad language on your podcast
you can anything you have to say that
you think is necessary you're
free to say okay well the patient would
aim the prison would come in and say
i got this headache so i would
say
well before we go any further can you
tell me the difference between a
headache and a headache
tell me the difference and he would say
well that's how i speak and i say
yes that's what i'm complaining of and
and he said well why shouldn't i
why shouldn't i speak like this because
that's me you know and i said well
supposing at the end of this
consultation i say to you and i hear
some pills
take two of the every four
hours
and if they don't work
come back and i'll give you some other
fighters
you you find this a bit strange wouldn't
you
so he said we'll say he said yes so i
said well
we're equal i don't talk to you like
that and you don't talk to me like that
and they just stopped and you meant that
what that you meant that i meant that
yeah yeah right
well that so you know so um you're
complimenting
you're complimenting your client
instantly you're saying look you know
we're engaged in a serious enterprise
here and i actually care about it and
maybe we should attend to the words
we're using you too
or we're just playing and i actually
care about you getting better
so how about we watch our language i'll
do it you do it and and
you know you can do it and so yes people
are going to agree to
use that i mean listen i used to have a
good laugh sometimes
i remember that law was that every
prisoner had to be examined medically
within
24 hours of being received into the
prison and in
practice it was usually within two hours
of being received in prison
and i used to do these um
i used to do these uh uh
examinations and one prisoner said he
wanted his medicine and
i didn't think he should have what he
was he alleged he was taking i had no
idea whether he was taking it or not
and i said i see no medical in
indication for him
and he started screaming he said uh
you murderer said
you're a murderer you're not a doctor
you're a murderer and of course
this was a victorian prison with um uh
with iron work and everything so it was
echoing all
through this enormous building
and anyway in the end i said well that's
enough you have to go
now and um so he went and uh
screaming still and all
and then the next day i saw him and he
came up to me and he apologized
and um and he said i was
i was bang out of order that was his
expression i was bang out of order i'm
sorry doctor i said oh never mind i said
i've been called far worse than that and
and then then i said and actually you
you
had a wonderful effect on the other
prisoners who i
whom i was examining because they were
like lambs when they came in
and
and i said you couldn't come and do it
again this evening could you
come in and call me a murderer so we had
a good laugh um
and but on the other hand of course
what i was saying is that you can
control yourself it's not uh
well that's and that's a compliment it's
a compliment and it might be the first
time that some of these people had been
complimented in that way
well yes i mean i i unfortunately i
think that services have been set up
to make them the victims of their own
lives and behavior
so that that's how they presented
himself and i remember another
another person who came in and said
now he had he'd been in prison several
times for burglary
and such of the british police that
really
you have to be want to be caught to be
caught by the british police for
burglary
but anyway um he said to me doctor do
you think
do you think my uh burglaring got
anything
do you think it's my childhood that
caused me to burgle
do you think it's got something to do
with my childhood so i said
absolutely nothing whatever and
and he said what
because he expected me to say it must be
and then so so
why do i do it i said well it's quite
simple
you're lazy and stupid and you're not
prepared to work for what it is that you
want
and he laughed instead of being very
angry he laughed
and because he knew
that what he was saying was nonsense um
and then after that we could talk about
his childhood because it was true
that his childhood was a bad one and
most of the prisoners
have a very bad child
many of them had very bad childhood that
that was all true
but it's not true that everyone who has
a bad childhood is a burglar
right just as it's not true that
everyone who's sexually molested grows
up to be a molester even though
many molesters were molested yes
yeah yeah right so
there were lots of other uh cases like
that i remember
a chat came to me i mean
prisoners were said to be of low
intelligence
on average lower than average
all i can say is that i never found them
incapable of understanding what i was
saying
now maybe what i'm saying isn't very
intelligent so it's easy for
unintelligent people
to understand it but nevertheless
i found that they could actually follow
quite complicated arguments i'll give
you an example there is
also isn't a clear relationship between
iq and anti-social behavior
and partly it's complicated too because
many prisoners have histories of head
trauma
often from violence and from child abuse
and and
damage from alcoholism and so on but i
know i know the literature on antisocial
behavior we looked at predictors for
years and even neuropsychological tests
that assess
prefrontal function for example which is
hypothetically the seat of inhibition
or higher order cognition the predictive
power of
of cognitive ability in relationship to
criminality is really quite low
and iq is completely uncorrelated with
conscientiousness
which is a personality factor and with
agreeableness so yeah so well i have
obvious that criminals are stupid
yeah i know i i i never i personally
never found that and
for example there was a trap came to me
and said
you have to give me something because
um if you don't give me something
i'm going to go and attack a child
sex offender in the prison that actually
they we
generally they were kept apart because
they would be immediately
attacked but anyway he said i i i'm
going to kill one
if i if i get hold of one if you don't
do something
i said well let's think about this he
said well why do you feel like that and
he said well because
they interfere with kiddies
with children and so i took a bit of a
risk i said do you have any children
and he said yes
three i said how many mothers
and he said well three i said
and um these mothers do they have
boyfriends and
and uh they said yes and i said one
or perhaps more have they had more than
one and
they said yes i said well
um is it likely that one or more of
these boyfriends has
sexually interfered with one of your
children
and he immediately got the point
and and i said well you're not a sex
you haven't interfered sexually with
children yourself but you facilitated
such you've created the conditions in
which
such behavior is likely to occur
now it's too late you can't do anything
about it now it's too late but you can
make sure
that you don't do anything to further it
in the future
and he went out he there was no more
talk about
uh killing uh
sex abusers why and why do you think you
got away with that
go right away well you said you said you
took a risk
right so well i took her yes well i took
a risk uh
i mean it was a risk that i didn't know
that he had children i didn't know what
i mean i had a fair idea because it was
a it was
so common amongst prisoners sure
and and outside prison but it's all it's
also a risk i mean the risk you took
he asked you to do something because he
was going to become murderous
and so that's a pretty uh uh salient
immediate
and credible threat given that a violent
criminal uttered it in a prison
yes and your response wasn't i better
prescribe him a sedative
at least to cover myself up let's say if
anything does happen
your response was let's call this guy
out for his
uh rather self-evident moral flaws
blind ignorance of which is facilitating
an unearned sense of homicidal
moral superiority and let's assume that
that's going to be curative
that's a risk yeah it it
it's a risk and i must say that when i
had
and i had lots of quite a few patients
who said similar things
uh and i didn't give
in to what was in essence moral
blackmail
but of course it did always occur to me
that maybe
one day one of these people who was
threatening something like that
might actually uh commit the act uh
and then someone might blame me i mean
yes
definitely that that never happened that
that never happened um but i
was i'm quite
i was fairly clear that
their responsibility their
responsibility was not to behave like
that
and um and he didn't
in my opinion as far as i could tell
suffer from
anything which uh
which would have excused him right some
some organic impulse control disorder
some prefrontal damage yeah
i mean those things do occur a certain
percentage of violent criminals have
um rage that's induced by epilepsy and
that can be triggered by
drinking and i mean there are organic
syndromes that mimic
virtually every moral failing yeah yeah
if he had a psycho psychosis for example
if he'd had a psychosis
i i wouldn't of course i wouldn't have
said what i said
um uh my sense in reading your books
like is so there is this sensoriousness
or
that something you could be criticized
about uh uh for
and i i'm sure and and you can tell me
about that i'm sure you have been
criticized for that
um and you know you'll you you've
written
provocative tracts like the toxic cult
of sentimentality
which is a real dagger in some sense i
mean because people
let's not call it sentimentality for a
moment let's call it empathy or sympathy
and you make a case that i think and
correct me if i'm wrong that
excessive empathy unthinking sympathy
is has has can produce catastrophic
consequences because it's not tempered
by judgment and
and then i look at the personality
literature you know we have two
moral personality traits roughly
speaking
one is agreeableness and so people who
are high in agreeableness are empathetic
and sympathetic and
self-sacrificing and perhaps resentful
because of it so it's not an untrammeled
virtue whereas the disagreeable types
are more likely to be imprisoned so
that's a predictor of of
of antisocial behavior but they're
they're
implacable and stubborn and hard to push
around and so
people vary on that distribution um
i think agreeableness is a the empathy
dimension is a trait that's
particularly good for fostering the care
of infants
because infants immediate empathy with
an infant
under six to nine months is almost
invariably the right response if the
infant is crying or
in distress your job isn't to question
or
judge it's to alleviate the source of
the
trouble and it's very hard to take care
of infants and it's no wonder that
there's a moral virtue that's
essentially devoted to the care of
true dependence but we have
conscientiousness too
and conscientiousness is the best
predictor of long-term life success
apart from iq and conscientious people
are good at
um keep formulating and keeping
contracts long-term contracts
it's sort of a cold virtue and they are
judgmental
but as far as i'm concerned we wouldn't
have both these personality traits like
they're two of
five so it's not like it's a trivial
proportion of the variation in
personality
we wouldn't have two of our five
personality traits
um aimed at regulating our behavior if
empathy alone was sufficient
and so you go after it the toxic cult of
sentimentality
what do you mean by that well i mean the
uh
if if you like the the uh
the infantilization of of people who
are expressing emotion so
uh we accept now that uh i mean there's
if someone if someone expresses
distress we don't inquire where that
distress
comes from how it arose we just simply
try to alleviate it oscar wilde
of course said that sentimentality is
the
uh desire to have the emotion without
without the cost of the emotion um
[Music]
i suppose sentimentality is to uh
is uh is to empathy what
kitsch is to art um
and so what would you regard okay so
let's
get i'll give you i mean i start the
book with an example
which i read in my local newspaper which
was of
a man who bought a chicken in a
supermarket
uh and roasted it or and then
gave it to they were eating their dinner
and the girl uh the little girl
finds that there are chickens feet in it
and screams with horror and so the
father and the
the child is so horrified that the
father says
i don't know whether this is what he did
literally but i had to throw it out of
the window
so he just took the emotion of the child
and said
i have to assuage that emotion
any way i can and the quickest way is
the best because of course
she would have less emotion if it's
dealt with quickly
so there's no there's no rational
there's no attempt to argue rationally
about
uh about this that actually chickens do
have feet
and they were live creatures once and
this is
something that children have to learn
it's one of the things that children
have to know and so what's the problem
with
reflexive empathy exactly
well it's not exactly empathy actually
okay okay
i i think it's not genuine well then we
we should define it
genuine empathy we should define genuine
empathy and distinguish it from
counterproductive sentimentality
yeah well it's not it's not easy
fair enough i i know i'm i i'm putting
you on the spot in this i'm saying that
that's something that could be
productively attempted
yes i'm not sure i have the complete
answer to that
uh you you you're hitting at it from all
sorts of different directions though you
know like one of the things that
that emerges from your book and and
you know i i saw you as someone who
wanted genuinely to be of help
to the people that you were seeing and
tortured by this
constant immersion that you had in
absolute bloody
nightmarish catastrophe like
to a degree that i don't really
understand how you managed
outraged by what you saw outraged by the
thoughtless contribution of skeptical
and critical intellectuals to this
suffering which is swept under the table
in some sense or or attributed only to
you know the power hungry
depredations of capitalism or something
like that and so you're outraged by that
and you're trying to use your capacity
for
judgment to help your clients your
patients
distinguish between those things that
they're doing that clearly hurt them
and those things that help them and also
to attribute to them the capacity to do
that which
like i was talking to my wife today she
we were talking about
a woman she's dealing with who is having
a hard time disciplining her one and a
half year old and
you know i mentioned to her that one of
the things i've seen among especially my
seriously affected clinical clients is
that
they actually have no idea that they
could change their behavior in a manner
that would improve
the future that as a concept that's not
part of the subculture that they're
embedded in and
that's so counterproductive and
unhelpful just hindering it
we also of course give them incentives
not to think like that
because if you have us
if in fact you have a situation in which
uh changing their behavior will not
improve that certainly their economic
situation very much
um which is actually the condition would
the situation of many of my patients
that takes away one of the possible
incentives
for changing behavior and why
is it that that finding gainful
employment for example
isn't going to produce a material change
in circumstances why how is it that this
is
at the level of detail because you uh
many of people if they go to work
they lose benefits they have to start
paying for things which were previously
paid for them
so they end up going to work
uh for x number of hours
and being uh very slightly
better off in monetary terms which
doesn't seem to them to be worth it
and i can understand that so you're
asking them to
do low-level jobs get up maybe at six
o'clock in the morning
and furthermore of course it's not good
for their children because
often they are single parents so they've
got no support at home
other than other than whatever it is
the state provides them
and uh they had so they have to manage
their children
and going to work when it's it's very
difficult
for them right for no for no economic
incentive
for well i mean they literally
marginally better off
mm-hmm well maybe maybe they have to buy
clothes there's it's expensive to work
you
you enter the workforce it's not trivial
they have to arrange transportation
that's also an expense and then you said
child care that's a devastating expense
because most people who
would work on the margins don't make
enough money to afford child care
at all let alone child care of any
quality yeah and so
so it also means that this this
unwillingness to
pass judgment let's say on the part of
helpers
um also means that we're we abdicate our
responsibility to design social welfare
systems
that would reward productive behavior
because we don't want to make the
judgments about what behaviors are
productive
and what aren't at least partly because
we don't want to make mistakes and throw
people out that
are deserving but we can't differentiate
but then
because we won't make those judgments we
produce systems that
counterproductively reward the kinds of
behaviors that produce the problems we
want to solve
they treat everybody as helpless and uh
and it's a kind of
learned helplessness actually and if you
look at
i mean it's very interesting to see the
the success the economic success of
uh certain groups of poor immigrants
for example the sikhs in britain
and i'm sure and certainly in canada
they may come with nothing but within a
very short time
they've succeeded they've risen up the
social scale their social and economic
scale
well you see that with first generation
asian immigrants in north america so
i looked into that in detail because
because it's a very interesting
phenomenon
i was interested in the relationship
between iq and conscientiousness
iq and personality in predicting
long-term life outcomes
and by and large people with higher iqs
do substantially better so if you had to
pick one attribute to ensure your
success
at birth it would be high intelligence
it's it's better to be born
three standard deviations above the mean
in iq
then three standard deviations above the
mean in wealth
in terms of your position at 40 so 40
years later so
iq is very powerful conscientiousness is
also powerful but only about a third is
much but
it's still powerful enough so that asian
immigrants their fur their children um
perform on average um as well as
native born caucasians who have a 15 iq
point advantage
which is roughly the difference between
a college student and a high school
student
and so there's something in the asian
culture and what it is is quite clear
actually it's it's uh um
it's uh incredibly intense work ethic
and respect for achievement
disciplined achievement in the economic
realm
that's hammered in right from now that
disappears after about two generations
yes but presumably also there's the
maintenance of the family structure
so that uh i mean you don't
certainly where i was anyway you didn't
get this this
complete breakdown i mean i never met uh
i never met uh children of
indian immigrants who didn't know who
their father was right right
well and that's an interesting
phenomenon too um i went to a
talk at one point at the university five
or six years ago
and uh a feminist was speaking uh
or a former feminist maybe still maybe a
real feminist now
her name was janice fiomingo and she had
been a radical leftist
feminist and was in the english
literature department and
and eventually realized that what she
was involved in was a
an academic scam fundamentally and
turned into quite a vocal critic of that
particular perspective
post-modern say neil marx's perspective
she mentioned to the audience that
families with intact families with
fathers
the children in those families do much
better on virtually every measure you
can possibly imagine and
in my naivety at that point i thought
well that's going to be an
incontrovertible
uh statement because all you have to do
is be
remotely familiar with the childhood
development literature and you figure
that out right away
and yet it was as if she dropped a live
snake into the audience because
and this is this is that toxic
sentimentality that you were talking
about say well
look there are obviously struggling
single parents
who are struggling for no fault of their
own
a perfectly credible job of raising
high performing children
and then if you say well the two-parent
family is
more desirable by implication you're
denigrating
that accomplishment let's say but and
and fair enough there is a real tension
there and and
there are exceptions to the rule but
it's still the case that if you were
trying to design public policy
that was of benefit to children you
would design public policy that would
reward people for
long-term monogamous relationships where
one of the
one of the participants was male 1 yeah
but you need to use judgment for that
yes
but if you look at i mean if you look at
uh literature for example there has been
a consistent attack on that
on that view um for many many years
going back
uh for example the fabians and and so on
and and what happens is that people
use marginal cases uh as
being central so
and as i've already said that it's
undoubtedly true that many marriages
were oppressive
um and that being in a
in an unhappy uh marriage uh
is a horrible experience it's a terrible
experience it's a long form of torture
but uh people then thought that there
was a perfect solution to this problem
there's a perfect solution to human
relationships
and there is no perfect relationship a
perfect
solution there's only better and worse
and whatever whatever
form of human relationships you're going
to have there are going to be terrible
ones but
you as far as i could see and i had
no real no real opinion about this until
i actually
immersed myself in the world in which i
did immerse myself it's quite clear to
me that
without without a formal structure
of relationships things are absolutely
terrible
for for very large numbers of people now
of course it's perfectly true that i
i saw if you like only the failed cases
or
but there may have been a question then
would be well where would you find the
successful cases
because let's think this through because
it's it's crucial point you know
okay so you have a biased sample and
maybe you approach this from an
ethically conservative perspective and
so that produces your
viewpoint and it bears little
relationship to the real world
but let's look for the counter example
so well first of all you can't look
among the high
functioning middle to upper classes for
counter examples because they're all
married
yeah right so so so then you think well
is there a subset of people who are poor
who are flourishing in their serial
relationships in their fragmented serial
relationships and well first of all
probably not because they're poor
right by definition you've already
excluded the middle and upper class
so i'm kind of curious about well i mean
i tried to think i
i thought well how is someone living in
these circumstances supposed to get out
of
out of this situation right what would
look like a viable
practical alternative that would be
better
that yes but didn't involve changing the
way they
made their relationships or pursued
their relationships
so they have to do we have to keep the
relationship
[Music]
the structure of the relationships the
same what can they
what else can they do that would make
their lives
better and i just couldn't see how their
lives could get better
while you have this kind of um
this kind of free-for-all it wasn't
really free for all it was free for some
and um so i came to the conclusion that
that it was a it was a social and
cultural disaster
well so let's we could look at the
fantasies of sexual libertarianism let's
say
and i think a good place to look and you
know i might be way off base here but
whatever i'm gonna forge forward let's
look at
uh playboy cause playboy was the first
mass market magazine that sort of
introduced the idea of
sophisticated sexual freedom into the
mass audience right and that quickly
degenerated into penthouse and hustler
and then to this bloody online
catastrophe where
everything goes and and it's a cesspit
of
unimaginable proportions but in any case
back to playboy um well you know
you have two sophisticated people the
woman's in her early 20s
the guys may be five years older than
that they both have a glass of
nicely aged wine they're sitting in a
50s
living room that's sophisticated
discussing literature
and they're both free to make their
choices and and so they have sex and and
then maybe your life is an unending
sequence of those perfect dates
it's like well what are the
preconditions for that
for that even to be possible well you
both have to be young
you both have to be attractive you both
have to be healthy
you both have to be rich you both have
to be educated
in all likelihood so that you're not
rife with psychopathology
um so that that can be an enjoyable and
civilized evening let's say well you
have to have come from a pretty stable
family
probably one with mother and father
intact and
and certainly not characterized by the
constant
unwanted serial switching of partners
i mean it's virtually unattainable
except in an unbelievably protected
environment
but you you're in that environment you
think well i could maybe you're in a
marriage and you're unhappy you have all
those attributes you think well i could
jump out of that into this fantasy
and everyone could share the fantasy but
no they couldn't
it's not possible but it uh i mean
actually what people are really doing
and
i mean uh one of the one of the most
important figures in um
in modern cultural histories marie
antoinette
who uh played shepherdess who went out
and thought it would be nice to be a
shepherdess and
went out to be a shepherdess for the day
but then always returned to her palace
and that this is what these people are
doing because
probably they give up that life
at some point the the people that you
the rich
people you've described and they
actually settle down more or less well
in very
if they don't they're not happy about it
yeah right
if if they don't it's because they
failed to get what they're actually
aiming incidentally
one interesting thing was that i would
talk
to mothers or single mothers
about what they wanted for their
daughters and what they wanted for their
daughters
was for them to find a nice man who
would have a good job
and would treat them decently and
uh they'd buy a house and so on and so
forth
so but they had no idea how
uh to encourage them right they have no
idea what the micro elements are
no no none whatever you see this in
illiterate families too is that
if you ask them do you want your
children to be educated
they say yes but if but there's no books
in the house
and they don't know where to buy a book
and they're intimidated by books and if
they have a book they don't know how to
read it to their child
you know and you get these huge
differences
at by the age of three between children
illiterate and non-literate households
that
the three-year-olds in literate
households might have been exposed to
you know a thousand hours worth of books
by the time they're three
they can already sit in the child in a
house like that you give them a book
they know what it is they'll sit there
and mime the action of reading they go
through the pages they point at the
pictures
they have all these pre-literate
behaviors
built in that that's the necessary
scaffold for the development of literacy
and there's micro habits that that that
are invisible if you're in that culture
they're invisible because they're just
part of how you live
like the fact that you have a bookshelf
like the fact that your relatives buy
your children books
if then if you don't know how to do that
at all the barriers to entry are
unbelievably unforgiving
yes and probably also uh
nobody tries to make up for it on on the
behalf of the parents
so i mean there's the schools are
themselves now doubt the value of
of literacy some of them
they that teachers don't know what
they're supposed to be
teaching or or at least or alternatively
a lot of them are more interested in the
ideological
correctness of of the children than they
are in their ability to read
well it's actually quite difficult to
teach children to read
you have to pay attention to each child
then they they radically differ in their
intellectual ability
and then you actually have to know how
to teach someone to read
and that's actually complicated you
start with the letters you you get the
letters pronounced you get two word
two-letter combinations and three-letter
combinations you automatize that
it's effortful ideological
indoctrination that's relatively
straightforward
yeah well i've i mean i can't really
speak about this because i never tried
to teach anybody to read
i had um an interesting experience well
the data on that the data on that are
pretty clear if you teach children to
read
using phonetics yes which breaks it
you know we have a phonetic alphabet
because that makes things easier you
don't
you only have to remember 26 characters
and variants on them instead of 10 000
say you teach the phonemes and you get
them to aggregate them and
once they get to the point where they
can read phrases they start to
read on their own account because it
becomes rewarding if you use other
methods they don't learn as well
well one one thing that i saw with my my
patient i was interested in their
their level of education which was
catastrophically low
i mean it was unbelievably low and i
would give them something to read
and they would you could see
that they had difficulty doing it and i
asked them to read it out loud
and then when they came to a long word
they would say
i don't know that one word i don't know
that one
as if english were written in idiographs
in chinese yes
in chinese mandarin yeah definitely some
teachers teach an idiogram method of
verbal apprehension which is absolutely
counterproductive that's how experts
read but that's not how you learn to
read
yes no and and then i would say
when they got through it i would ask
them
what did it mean and they would say
i don't know i was only reading it
unless you can read phrases at a glance
you spend so much intellectual energy
decoding the phonemes
and the letters that you can't read for
meaning
and that's why it's not rewarding to
begin with right you have to go through
that slog of automatizing the
subroutines and
and and that happens much more uh
much at a much earlier age in literate
households yeah
well i just i thought what i found
very strange was that there was no sense
of outrage that we
spend on average a hundred thousand
dollars probably more
on each pupils education
and about 20 of them come out
functionally illiterate or barely
literate the kind of people that i'm
talking about who
who couldn't read a phrase or
who had difficulty sounding it out and
then at the end of it
uh didn't know what it meant now how is
it possible to spend
so much money and have
these results and
this has a catastrophic effect on their
lives it's obvious that it must
in any modern society it must have a
catastrophic effect on their lives
but nobody seemed to be interested or or
saw it as a disaster
you'd think the faculties of education
would be interested
and you'd think that by now they would
have
it'll say say assessed an immense
variety of
methods to teach children how to read
let's say because i think pretty much
everybody could agree that that would be
good you know that they would have tried
out 200 different educational techniques
subjected them to stringent analysis
and that we would see an increase in the
efficiency of treating of
teaching children to read that would be
in keeping with the increase in
technological power that we've seen over
the last 20 years we should be teaching
kids to read at a rate that's just
beyond comprehension if the faculties of
education were doing their jobs
which they're not quite the contrary
so yes that's a and i was thinking too
you know this
one of the things i found really
interesting working with people who were
dispossessed was
you know you might think well you don't
want to impose these external norms on
them there's there's a form of
colonialism that would be associated
with that
or or classism or something like that
and and i suppose that's part of the
non-judgmental stance but you can always
just ask the people themselves
and what you find right away is they
they want
for themselves pretty much what the
middle class
person or the upper class person has and
i don't just mean material resources
they
they'd rather be educated than not
educated or at least they'd want that
for their children
they'd rather have a relationship if
they could figure out how to
conceive of it that was stable and
loving all of these things that
you know you could regard as arbitrary
a child would rather have a father and a
mother that were around
so there we could derive
norms for the direction of our social
policies
that could be derived from the
populations that were hypothetically
trying to serve
but we don't seem to do that either we
can't even agree that
all things considered it would be better
to foster
to reward the presence of two parent
families
yeah yes well i mean
all that i said in my books i thought
was common sense actually
everything was more or less common sound
it wasn't
then it wasn't work of great reflection
or
anything like that it just seemed to me
everything was obvious um
and yet um and yet it takes
maybe it takes exposure to twenty 000
cataclysmic failures to make what's
obvious
salient you know because the problem
with what's obvious is that it's
invisible
you know i i found this out many times
so if i'm called on in an
interview for example to defend marriage
i think well i don't actually know how
to defend
something that until 10 years ago was
taken as a self-evident
good it's not like i have or any of us
for that matter have a
mass massive array of arguments at hand
to justify cultural norms in
the fact that they're norms means you
don't have the arguments at hand they're
they're so
self-evident that they're not buttressed
by a differentiated description
yeah well you see i
i once i used to write for a left-wing
magazine as well as the spectator which
is conservative
called the new statesman i mean it's not
far left it's um
you know moderately left
and i used to go for lunch there
uh sometimes and we would have a
discussion and i met a
a very distinguished bbc broadcaster in
the days when the bbc
actually was not terrible and
um and he said he'd read me
and then he said i i wanted to meet you
because i wanted to ask you as
uh he said uh do you make it up
do you make it up yeah so i said
well i'm very flattered that you think i
could make it up
but i don't make it up on the contrary i
i i tone it down
and of course i do disguise it for
to so that people are not recognizable
but
but in essence everything is true and
actually things are much worse than that
well the thing is think things in a bad
situation things are so bad
that it's both inconceivable and
incommunicable
to the people that it's happening to and
to anyone else like i've
been in families that were dysfunctional
for multiple generations
and what i found was that in some
situations
you dig and you get to a lie and you
think god i finally got to the
fundamental lie and then
you'd find that there was a a lie
underneath that that was even bigger and
then if you dug through that you'd find
another catastrophe that was even more
cataclysmic and it just never came to an
end
you you can't communicate
what did you say in one of your books i
think it was you quoted tolstoy
every unhappy family is unhappy in its
own way
yes right so there's this specificity of
misery
that's complex beyond belief and and
densely layered and so i know that
reading your accounts which are you know
hair
raising and heart rending that's nowhere
near as bad as the actual situation
yes yeah well i used to go into the
hospital thinking
i had heard everything i've heard
everything they can't surprise me can't
surprise me
but they always could surprise me the
there was a kind of uh creativity
about about the miseries
that people inflicted on each other
without
i mean what was distressing to me about
the
misery that i saw is that it was not
actually
there wasn't a government inflicting it
not certainly not directly
it was it was not like the misery of
shall we say mass
deportation or uh you know
civil war or anything like that but in a
way that made it because i
i used to have not exactly a hobby but i
used to have a taste for going to
dangerous countries
and places where there was civil war
where everything had broken down
and in a way i found it less distressing
than the kind of breakdown that i was
that i was seeing around me in
england because it was in a way it was
unforced
right well let me ask you about that
then for a second
i mean you're making two arguments
you were making two arguments just then
and i think you this happens regularly
is that
there is an underclass so three
arguments there is an underclass that
has a multi-generational component um
things are really really bad in that
class for
all sorts of complex site reasons many
of which
are philosophical let's say or ethical
or moral
and it's worse than it was and i guess
of the three of those the one i find
least convincing let's say or
i'm able to accept with less certainty
is the idea that things are actually
worse
i mean people you know if you go back to
1820s
and this is maybe where your experience
in poor places
in developing worlds might be useful if
you go back to 1840 or thereabouts
the typical person in the western world
lived on about a buck 90 a day
in today's dollar so below the un
poverty level life was bloody brutal for
people
and you know so maybe things are worse
now
in the lower class with regards to
familial structure than they were for a
brief period after the second world war
but
it isn't obvious to me that they're
necessarily worse by historical stuff
i mean it's so yeah it's always a
question of when you say something is
worse
there's always the question of what
you're comparing it well yes
so i mean you know we could compare it
with 3000 bc or
or or 1100 or whatever
um i the things that
it's incontestable that we are vastly
better
off physically than that's incontestable
and um i mean when my
my father was born in the east end of
london and in his
borough the um when he was born 1909
the infant mortality rate was
if i remember rightly 124 per thousand
which means that
uh an eighth of children died before
their first
birthday and in 18th century
london 50 of children died before they
were five
and there was you know poverty and filth
and
epidemic disease and every kind of so
but i don't think that that's the kind
of standard of comparison we
we should use and if we take something
like
crime um violent crime
i think the evidence is that it has
increased enormously
in a country like britain uh since 1900
when of course real
there was absolutely terrible poverty by
our standards today
the kind of poverty that nobody suffers
today
in any in any western society
and i was very struck by
um by the story of um
jack the ripper they're very instructive
things which some people haven't noticed
which was that
in white chapel which was regarded as
the worst part of london
in the 1880s and was i mean the policy
was just
again inconceivable to us now
when a body was found people ran off to
find a policeman
and they found a policeman and the
policeman was
armed with a bull's-eye lamp
he had a truncheon which he was supposed
to draw
only in extremis and he had a whistle
and that was how he was armed and he
went around white chapel
one by one not not in pairs or not in
groups
but with one birth so
in white chapel today you wouldn't get a
policeman doing that
so i'm i am confused about that to some
degree because
you know they're stephen pinker for
example i mean he makes a pretty strong
case that overall your probability of
um being murdered for example has just
against its time frame issue is
declining well it depends where yes what
you're starting
where you're starting with the future so
i i think the more i think the more
powerful argument is not necessarily so
much
that things have tell me what you think
about this
it could easily be that there's a
degeneration
of moral standards let's say that leads
to
a higher probability of um dispossession
and that you see that in the
uh in the in the in the class that's
that's dropped out of society and that
is a consequence of
what would you say uh a failure
a failure to abide by the same standards
that
might motivate middle-class prosperity
and maybe the expectations for that
class have
have have transformed themselves over a
20-year period but
it isn't obvious to me necessarily that
that's associated with an increase in
in criminality overall well i
again i think that well certainly in
britain it's perfectly clear that
things like burglary and assault have
increased
enormous i mean they're not increasing
they're not increasing further and they
might now be decreasing
but they've increased enormously by
comparison with
with the fairly recent past i'm not
talking about
18th century uh london when you couldn't
go anywhere without meeting a footpad or
anything like that
if i'm i mean this is slightly
uh slightly altering the subject a
little i'm
i personally am not terribly keen on the
idea of the underclass because i don't
i this suggests that it's a bit like um
marx's lump and proletariat if you like
uh
this is five percent of the population
or whatever percentage of the population
that is very
uh separate from the rest of the
population
unfortunately as this was one of the
points
in my some of my books anyway uh
the cultural uh influence
is going from the
is flowing from the bottom now upwards
rather than what used to be the case
from from middle classes or upper
classes and middle classes
downwards so that aspiration was
to move upwards but now there seems to
be
a cultural um
a desire for cultural um
decline or descent
it seems to me yeah you make that case
with an
upper-class mimicry of of lower class
let's say lower economic class styles
and that
and that sort of thing which is a form
of marry antoinettism
because of course they hang on to their
economic
advantages right
right right well then they get the
advantages of being dispossessed and the
advantages of being rich
um let me ask you we're going to have to
draw to a close here
relatively quickly unfortunately um
what are there other people writing
in the same vein as you and that's one
question the other question is
what kind what has been the consequence
for you of
your writing and your popularization of
these ideas i'd also like to know
what sort of audience you're reaching
your your most
successful book let's say if you
consider success
popularity was life at the bottom
correct that's 2001.
and that one i think it's fair to say
that that one
brought you to wide public attention
by writer's standards by non-fiction
writers standards let's say
um what's been the consequence what kind
of criticisms have you
faced and and how have you responded to
what's been the consequence of that for
you as well
yeah well the first thing is i don't
think many people are writing in my vein
there was a
a journalist a left-wing journalist
called nick davis who wrote about this
and he admitted the phenomena so
he didn't deny the phenomena his
analysis of the causes of it was
different
but i but nick davis nick davis yes
what did he write i've forgotten the
time okay i'll look it up i'll look it
up
yeah i mean interesting and i didn't of
course i didn't agree with his analysis
of the causes
but he did admit that the phenomena were
there
which and all and we are very reluctant
to admit that the phenomena are there
and if they are admitted they're
regarded as amusing
there was a very interesting
uh video made about the toki
it was called the toki family in um
in holland and this was a sort of
underclass family
which was drinking and taking drugs and
it was making the lives
of its neighbors terrible and they
i mean i don't like to use the word
degenerates but that's the word that
comes to mind
and finally they they managed
something which is very difficult in
holland they were evicted from where
they were living
and this is almost and there's an
impossible achievement in holland but
anyway
they went off in their white van
and their consequence was that they were
going on holiday to
their punishment for their behavior was
going on holiday to spain in a white van
and some producer
made a little um video of them uh
singing that they were going on holiday
to spain in in there and you see them
drinking
and you know
just as my they were just like my
patients
and what it was quite clear to me was
that they were being exhibited
as amusing to the middle classes of
holland it was just a joke but these
people
were not a joke they were they'd been
very violent to their
neighbors they'd made their live the
lives of
their neighbors hell and
what we saw was the metropolitan middle
classes
just turning them into a joke as if
their lives and the lives of the people
around them
were not to be taken seriously
so that i think is i mean that i think
is the attitude of
of the kind of people who have no
contact
with this world as i would have had no
contact with the world with this world
if i if i hadn't done the work i i did
as to consequences for me
haven't really been any i haven't been
viciously attacked
um why not
i think well first of all it helps to be
a doctor
secondly right well you have some
credibility too because you're you know
you're actually working directly
well that was that i think was it this
yeah this was not
this was uh this was my ideas weren't
just born out of
some kind of theoretical uh
superstructure
so for all your flaws you're you're
genuinely in the trenches
and that comes across you know that
comes across immediately just the sheer
number of people that
i mean it's you saw how many people who
had tried to commit suicide well but i
think it was ten thousand
ten and fifteen thousand right so that's
that's such an inconceivable number that
it sort of i would imagine it would sort
of leave critics aghast it's like well
i've never talked to three people like
that and you've talked to 15
000 that's that's actually quite a
difference so the best way of dealing
with that
is to ignore it
you know so i i mean you say i'm well
known i don't think i'm well known
i mean it's true that my book has i
don't know how many
i don't know how many my book is uh
sold i was very surprised to discover
that it sold 13 000 in the netherlands
and i was surprised because actually
what i was describing was england and i
couldn't see
how that could interest a dutch audience
but
many people have
have said well i have observed this many
people who are in the trenches
as it were and one of the things that
really pleased me
i mean this was possibly the most
pleasing thing to me
was that i i oddly enough my
the books have sold quite well in brazil
of all countries i mean i never
it never occurred to me that they might
sell in brazil
and i gave a lecture in sao paulo and
people came up afterwards they wanted to
book sign
and there were a couple among them
who said we are for
we were born in the favelas of
of sao paulo which actually are not the
worst in brazil but
but still pretty bad and it's said
we recognized all that you said
all that you said about england we saw
in the favelas
so let's let's go through what what you
saw
and and then maybe we could talk about
what you've seen
and what you think might be effective
amelioration so you see
um fragmented
intimate relationships is that is that
the most salient
feature is the impermanence of intimate
relationships
i you know yes i would say so because i
think without
uh without better relationships it's
very difficult to see how large numbers
of people can escape this world
okay and so out of that because the
relationships the sexual relationships
aren't bound by mutual long-term
support love contractual obligations and
all of that
that spins into higher levels of male
violence and also to
predation on vulnerable females by
psychopathic and aggressive males
yes although i wouldn't say that the
the women are just passive uh victims
they're not just passive victims
i mean they are victims but they're not
passive victims i mean
and i guess i was sorry i was thinking
that they're they're easier
prey yeah with multiple children they're
not
they're they're easier pickings that's
that's what i mean
that's right yes right so the
fragmentation so
if you have a fragmented couple of
relationships and
and you're a woman you end up with
children you're no longer
20 and single you're 28 or 35 you have
two children
um your your the array of high quality
men that you have to choose from is
going to decrease substantially
yes it was never very great to begin
right right right okay so then we add to
that
um i studied alcohol for years
and its effects on violence and you can
basically say that
if people didn't get drunk half the
violence in the world would instantly
disappear
so rape murder
familial abuse the contribution of
alcoholism is
stunningly high stunningly high so maybe
that's the third factor
that plays in it is that reasonable well
it's certainly uh
it's unmistakably uh
part of it yes yeah say 50
of murderers are drunk when they kill
and 50 of victims are intoxicated when
they die
yeah so it's it's it's a major and it's
the only drug
it's the only drug that has that
magnitude of an effect on violent
behavior so
um then low
low educational attainment
yes that's obviously very important
and and interestingly the state does
very little to try to address it
or try to to make things better okay and
then
and then beliefs what what do you think
are the key beliefs that that
characterize the phenomenon that you saw
uh well there's
there is now certainly a sense of
entitlement
the sense of it's wrong for anyone to
judge
people have internalized that so not
only do they not
judge others but they don't judge
themselves and it's not right for
anybody to judge them
so that's an abandonment of judgment or
even a demonization of it when it's just
a crucial thing that you need to
separate your
but you can spend your life at the same
while at the same time because it's
existentially impossible not to make
judgments they are making judgments but
they don't
they are not they don't accept that
they're making judgments that they are
making judgments
um attitude towards the future
what's the attitude uh
i think uh shall we say it's not
thought about very deeply right okay so
that's the first thing is that it
doesn't come up much
yes but what i've noticed is is
that there there's no implicit sense
that the future is something that could
be altered for the
for the better by changes of behavior
currently
yes yeah which is
there's an element of truth in that in
the economic aspect
because then you know
they're not going to get good job even
if they behave responsibly and so on
they're not going to get good jobs
however their lives will be better
if they behave responsibly but another
thing that
i would i i mean this is very
speculative
but i thought that um
lots of people have become stars in
their own soap opera
and they prefer a a
a dramatic life a life full of incident
to a life that would be actually very
flat if they
if they did the kind of things that you
and i would suggest
their lives might be very flat because
they would not be well off
uh they would still be struggling
economically
and so on and their lives would be very
very dull
well that's dostoyevsy's famous
criticism of socialist utopia right
people are fundamentally unable to deal
with
uh satiated dullness they'll
break it they'll fragment it just so
that something dramatic and exciting
happens
and there's definitely truth and that i
think that's a testament to some degree
to the adventurousness of the human
spirit even though it's something that
can
well manifest it in the ways that you
described yeah well i think
i'm not boring yes well i mean i've fled
i mean i can't say that i haven't um
i haven't like chasing sensation myself
because i
when i was younger i used to like danger
of a certain kind i used to like
going to countries which were dangerous
i crossed africa by public transport
in days when it was impossible to
communicate with
anyone there were no mobile phones or
anything so i was in communicado for
months as well
and you did work in prisons as a
psychiatrist
yeah well i didn't i never felt really
that was very dangerous
but i'd um you know
countries where there's uh civil war and
and so on are dangerous and i liked it
uh
but i always felt i suppose maybe
falsely that there was some higher
purpose it wasn't just
a liking for danger there was
some kind of purpose behind it all
well there is some you there is some
utility in seeking out adventure and
and strife if that's integrated into a
functional and productive generous
honest life
that's better it's better so
um obviously in and of itself it can
become a problem but um
so how did you handle this
emotionally which um well the
endless onslaught of misery amongst your
amongst your clients i mean one way of
dealing with it of course was writing
about it
because i i've what i found is that when
you write about
an experience even an unpleasant
experience
it distances you from that experience so
you you not only having the experience
you're observing having the experience
i was once arrested in albania
and uh and mildly
say mildly beast with a truncheon
by a by policeman and actually as he was
hitting me
i i wasn't thinking this is painful i
was thinking how am i going to describe
this subsequently
so that being able to describe it or
having the intention of describing it
actually distances yourself in a good
way i think
from from your experience well you draw
the conclusions that way and
i mean the purpose of your memory in
some sense is to draw the appropriate
conclusions from your experience to
guide you into the future and so
um i have a series of writing exercises
online
at a place called selfauthoring.com that
steps people through writing a biography
and it highlights experiences that were
emotionally extreme
and because there is plenty of evidence
that writing them out
they have to be somewhat distant from
you you know
yes you can't do it the next day yes
exactly because you're just
re-traumatizing yourself in some sense
but the evidence is quite
strong i would say that doing that well
you're
transforming the emotion into words and
replacing in some sense the emotion by
the words you're making sense of it
um yeah there was a very interesting
experience i had an
interesting experience with that in that
regard in the prison
we had a writer who would come in and
teach
writing creative writing if you like
to interested prisoners and they were of
course a selected group
and so on and the writer told me he came
to me because of course the
the uh there wasn't really any evidence
that he was doing any
good because of course that such
evidence
would be almost impossible to to gather
right
but and so of course the prison
authorities
are constantly trying to cut down costs
so they want to get rid of
them so he wanted me to write in his
uh favor which i did which of course
sealed his fate
but um
but anyway uh he told me something very
interesting
all the people who wrote
wrote autobiographically as you would
expect
and they would they would come to a
point in their lives
when they had to stop when they found it
extremely difficult to go on
because actually what it did this was
the first time in their lives they'd
really ever thought biographically
or perhaps even thought well maybe
well i really mean that it's like you
know that people
think they think but what happens is
thoughts appear in their head
that's way different than sitting down
programmatically
and voluntarily going over your life and
trying to make sense
anyway they came they came to a point
where they couldn't go on at least for
quite a long time
and that point was when they realized
that all that they'd been telling
themselves about their own behavior was
actually false
and so i came to the conclusion that
this actually
now whether it changed their behavior
subsequently
i can't tell you i don't know and anyway
well you know you you probably need to
marry that with a plan
yeah you know like the problem is is
that if you
if you realize that what you're doing is
wrong
but it's habitual and you don't know
what else to do
you're going to do what you know because
what else are you going to do
you don't know anything else yeah i mean
one thing about
the statistics in an ending rate in
britain are quite clear that people stop
coming into prison on
new offenses i mean overwhelmingly not
not absolutely 100 but overwhelmingly
for for offenses like burglary and
they stop after the age of 39 and
um and their rate of
conviction goes down in the 30s so there
is a kind of spontaneous
change now whether this would accelerate
i mean what you would want to do is
accelerate that change
so that they they didn't have to reach
the age of
39 before they stopped committing those
crimes
and my guess was that
this did actually have an effect but i
have no proof
of that i have no proof that this yeah i
don't know of any studies that look at
autobiographical writing and recidivism
um well it would be very difficult
because it would be very difficult
very yeah you i mean it would be
difficult to find the control group
and and so on so but i mean
instinctively i felt that
this was a good thing to be doing
well insofar as thought is useful and
verbal thought is high quality thought
you'd hope that it would be helpful
um okay so how did your conclusions
change your clinical practice
for the better let's say in your opinion
and
what about social policy suggestions
well the the first clinical practice it
made me very wary of medicalization of
misery
[Music]
that's the first thing so that i spent
far more time
persuading people not to take medication
and
take it in fact there's a kind of law in
prison if
if people want medicine they don't need
it and if they won't take
it they do need it so
but um
as far as social policy is concerned i'm
very very wary of making
and perhaps this is very cowardly of me
very wary of making any
suggestions because
uh if anyone would take me seriously
and the results would work catastrophic
i i would feel very bad so
well it's an unfair actually i'm i'm i
think also that actually what we need is
a cultural
change and i'm not sure how much the
government can
bring about a cultural change so i was
trying to
in my way trying to persuade people
particularly the
the intellect maybe this is grandiose
but i was trying to
persuade intellectuals that a lot of
their
world outlook was was bad
and was doing harm rather than good
um um and to be and to be cognizant of
that
because of the fact that radicalism
translated down the socioeconomic
hierarchy is often
devastating yes yeah so that the
destruction of the family
which you know rich people perhaps
can survive is devastating for
people who need solidarity
social solidarity more than anybody else
and that the social solidarity which now
runs entirely through the state
is a very cold form of solidarity
that that is very unpleasant
that's a good place to stop yeah
thank you very much for your
conversation i've appreciate it
for for talking with me today i hope
everyone finds this useful
yeah i hope i don't know whether how
many people
um how many people watch or see it
a million a million yeah and you get
abuse that's a long story
i mean i know you haven't no i mean
abuse from this kind of thing the from a
podcast
no not at the moment and and and likely
not from this one
yes so yeah good
well uh yeah i i mean i must say i
i haven't really had abuse but then of
course i don't
i don't i don't look to see whether
people are
abusing me so what the heart doesn't see
what the eye doesn't see the heart can't
grieve over
much appreciated okay thank you very
much thank you very much
[Music]
you